gambling it's been in video games since
pretty much forever
of course it's often some sort of side
activity in an open world but even when
it's the focus it's usually just for fun
no one's losing anything you're gambling
fake video game money in the hopes of
getting even more fake video game money
but what if you introduce something
that's actually a bit closer to real
gambling for the last couple of years
some developers have augmented their
game's progression with loot boxes
chests or card packs that can cost real
money and don't always guarantee
something worthwhile and in the past
couple of months it's been debated
whether or not this should be considered
gambling the ESRB released a statement a
while ago saying it isn't but many don't
agree with that stance the writing
boards reasoning is that you'll always
get something in a loop box even if it's
something you don't want with gambling
in a casino racetrack or anywhere else
you're always at risk of losing your
money for nothing while there is that
stark difference that didn't stop the
Belgium Gaming Commission from launching
an investigation into overwatch and Star
Wars Battlefront two systems at the time
of this video however the Belgian
authorities ruling is still yet to be
made but in the wake of this news Hawaii
state representative Chris Lee spoke out
against battlefront to suit boxes and
announced he was taking action in order
to ensure there are future protections
for kids youth and everyone else this
game is a Star Wars themed online casino
designed to lure kids into spending
money it's a trap and this is something
that we need to address to ensure that
particularly kids who are underage or
not psychologically and and emotionally
mature enough to be able to gamble which
is why gambling is prohibited under 21
are protected from being trapped into
these cycles which have compelled many
folks to spend thousands of dollars and
gaming fees online Lee said that he's
looking at legislation to see about
prohibiting the sale of games like
battlefront 2 to underage customers in
addition to the actual prohibition of
certain mechanisms and games he added
that he's talking to other state reps to
work together on this situation
we don't know exactly where this is all
headed and while government officials
believe that loot boxes are in fact
gambling I'm more interested in the ways
gambling affects our minds and exactly
how games could be taking advantage of
that I spoke with two psychologists
about these subjects to dig into whether
they believe loot boxes constitute
gambling psychology professor Ronald
ratio talked to me specifically about
why it's so addictive and certain
concepts that drive people to feel good
about throwing down money it comes down
to basic psychology because gambling is
what we call variable ratio it's a
variable ratio payoff so what that means
is you have to keep playing in order to
win and because it's variable you never
know when you're gonna win it's a very
addicting sort of behavior so think of a
slot machine you got to pull the arm or
push the button yeah but you never know
when it's gonna pay off and it's that
sort of surprise element that makes it
so addicting ratio isn't familiar with
many of today's releases so we kept our
conversation away from specific games
and more focused on the actual
psychology of gambling and certain
concepts that loop box filled games
often bring with them the first of these
we talked about with social proof
while it's not exactly gambling ratio
said that shopping channels on
television often present how many people
have called in to buy a specific item to
show proof that the item is desirable or
beneficial to consumers this subject was
brought up after I talked to him about a
2015 Activision patent that was granted
this year the patent was for a
matchmaking system that would encourage
the purchasing of microtransactions the
text of the patent reads for example if
the player purchased a particular weapon
the microtransaction engine may match
the player in a gameplay session in
which the particular weapon is highly
effective this may encourage the player
to make future purchases to achieve
similar gameplay results another example
posited that the system could identify a
junior player and match them with
someone of a much higher skill level
this would be set up in the hopes that
the junior player would be encouraged to
quote make game related purchases such
as
rifle or other item used by the highly
skilled sniper of course once news broke
on this system Activision was quick to
release a statement saying the patent
was exploratory filed by an R&D team
that worked separately from its game
studios and had not been implemented in
any game Bungie was also quick to add
that it was not implemented in Destiny
too however a videogame doesn't need to
use this system to utilize social proof
against its players when killed in a
battlefront 2 multiplayer match you're
presented with your opponent's star
cards which could exploit a player's
frustration and push them to buy loot
boxes in an attempt to get better cards
and as you probably know EA recently
removed all of battlefront 2's
microtransactions but only temporarily
and it remains to be seen if the company
will implement a better more fair system
when the time comes
however battlefront 2 isn't the only
game with these types of problems
overwatch is seen by many as a game that
does loot boxes right and while all of
their contents are cosmetic and don't
affect the gameplay ratio stopped me
when I was explaining one particular
aspect overwatch is seasonal events
bring a lot of new cosmetic items to the
table particularly themed skins but
they're only available for a limited
time this pushes players to play as much
as possible in the hopes they get a
lucky box and as time dwindles the urge
to drop real money get stronger so
that's called a scarcity principle so we
have a limited time act now time is
limited right and so that makes it more
compelling and so it makes makes it more
likely that you're gonna gonna go for it
you know there's a psychologist his name
is Bob Sheldon he's actually a friend
and he's done a lot of research on the
kinds of factors that influence us to
cause us to kind of behave against maybe
our you know conscience in a sense one
of them is this scarcity principle and
so you know and he gives lots of
examples of when time is running out
people feel compelled well I'd better
get it now or I better gamble now to try
to get it because it will be available
later on ratio made it pretty clear to
me that he believes the boxes and video
games are a form of gambling even if it
is currently considered acceptable for
underage players however I also talked
to psychologist Jamie Madigan who do
votes a significant portion of his time
writing about the psychology of video
games he doesn't necessarily believe
loot boxes are gambling in the same
sense as casino games as he compared
them closer to blind toy boxes and
baseball cards however he does think
it's important for people to practice
the same kind of restraint and caution
as one would with gambling because
baseball card dealers don't use
predatory methods such as pay to win
persuasion to target players and make
them feel like they need to buy more
packs you look at something and you can
imagine or wonder if something predatory
is going on behind the scenes where you
know they know that like okay people in
this demographic and who engage in these
types of behaviors and that this profile
like if we offer to sell them a loop box
immediately after they lose a match then
that you know increases their chance of
buying by 3% or something like that you
know if that stuff's sort of stuff is
going on then it starts to get into like
well okay is this at the call you know
you're you're really trying to squeeze
people and and it starts to feel more
predatory there's also another issue to
consider many people are predisposed to
thinking that their odds are better once
they invest money both ratio and madigan
talked to me about a study that asked
people on a horse track about their odds
of winning it found that those placing
bets felt they had better odds once they
had put money on the line in the context
of video games like overwatch inbound
front to which offer players loot boxes
through putting in work or paying money
this bothered me I have experience with
friends believing that their odds are
better when paying for loot boxes in
overwatch now that's likely not the
actual case but it's a good reason as to
why Blizzard EA and others should be
more transparent about these systems in
the same way Blizzard revealed its loot
box odds in China it should do the same
everywhere else players shouldn't feel
like they need to spend money for a
better chance at the items they want of
course we don't actually know what
companies are doing behind the scenes to
make loot boxes more enticing for
players however before belgium and
hawaii spoke out against these systems
EA unsurprisingly said that their loot
boxes are not gambling and those are
chimed in as well saying it doesn't
believe overwatch is a part of the
controversy unfortunately when I reached
out to both companies for comment
Blizzard did
have anything more to say and ei didn't
reply at all we'll just have to wait and
see what happens now that government
authorities are involved but one thing
is clear loot boxes and
microtransactions aren't going away
anytime soon and we need to be vigilant
against practices that might be
predatory and acting against our best
interests
[Music]